TIME FOR OUR OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
IF YOU ARE THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
RULES AND PACES TO          PAYH
RULES AND PACES TO          PAYI
RULES AND PACES TO          PAYR
RULES AND PACES TO          PAYT
RULES AND PACES TO          PAYX
RULES AND PACES TO          PAYS
THAT WORKS HARD, PLAYS BY THE
RULES AND PACES TO          PAY.
GOOD AMERICANS NEED TO STEP BACK
TONIGHT.
THIS IS ABOUT REPUBLICAN,
DEMOCRAT, OR LIBERAL
WITH NO DUE PROCESS, ZERO
COOPERATING EVIDENCE.
THE LEFT IN AMERICA IS NOW
SMEARING AN INDIVIDUAL AND THEY
BEEN DOING IT NOW FOR 15
CONSECUTIVE DAYS.
CALLING HIM EVIL, ACCUSING HIM
OF BEING A SERIAL, A PREDATOR, A
LIAR, A PERJURER, MUCH MORE.
A MAN WHO HAS SERVED HIS COUNTRY
AND HAS BEEN IN THE SPOTLIGHT
NOW FOR ALMOST 40 YEARS WITHOUT
A SINGLE LIFT OF MISCONDUCT
UNTIL 15 DAYS AGO.
AS WE AMERICANS, WE BETTER GET
THIS AS A COUNTRY RIGHT.
THE ROG TO JUDGMENT, GETTING RID
OF ALL PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE
AND DUE PROCESS, IT IS A CLEAR
PRESENT DANGER TO ALL OF YOU, TO
EVERY AMERICAN.
TONIGHT AT A HUGE RALLY IN
JOHNSON CITY, TENNESSEE,
RESIDENT TRUMP TALKING ABOUT THE
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE AND THE
PILLAR OF WHAT IS AMERICANS A
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE,
LET'S WATCH THE PRESIDENT.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE WILLING TO DO
ANYTHING AND TO HURT ANYONE TO
GET THEIR WAY.
JUST LIKE THEY ARE DOING WITH
GEORGE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
[BOOS]
THEY BEEN TRYING TO DESTROY HIM
SINCE THE VERY FIRST SECOND HE
WAS ANNOUNCED BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT GEORGE BRETT KAVANAUGH WILL
FOLLOW THE CONSTITUTION AS
WRITTEN.
HE IS A GOOD MAN.
A GREAT STUDENT, GREAT
INTELLECT, HE HAS NEVER HAD A
PROBLEM AND ALL THE SUDDEN,
LET'S GO BACK TO HIGH SCHOOL.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD GO BEFORE
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEN THEY WANT
TO TAKE A LOT LONGER WITH THE
FBI.
NO, THE FBI --
IF WE TOOK TEN YEARS, THEY WOULD
WANT MORE TIME.
>> Hannity: HERE WE ARE ON DAY
15, JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
EDIT WILD PRESS CONFERENCE
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT LET
LOOSE AND HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT
THE IMPORTANT PROCESS THAT THE
MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING
TO KNOW A BAND.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
HE TOOK IT ON, TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WANT THE FBI --
THIS IS ANOTHER SEVENTH
INVESTIGATION.
IT IS NOT THEY ARE JUST
STARTING.
I WANT THEM TO DO A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION.
WHATEVER THAT MEANS ACCORDING TO
THE SENATORS AND THE REPUBLICANS
ON THE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY.
I WANT THEM TO DO THAT.
THE REASON I WOULD LIKE THEM TO
GO QUICKLY, TO SO SIMPLE.
BECAUSE IT IS UNFAIR TO HIM AT
THIS POINT.
WHAT HIS WIFE IS GOING THROUGH,
WHAT HIS BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN ARE
GOING THROUGH IS NOT
DESCRIBABLE.
IT IS NOT DESCRIBABLE.
IT IS NOT FAIR.
>> Hannity: OF COURSE HIS BOAT
WAS ONCE AGAIN DELAYED LAST WEEK
BECAUSE THE LEFT SUCCESSFULLY
COERCED A FLAKY REPUBLICAN, TO
GO ALONG WITH THEIR DEMANDS.
A NEW BACKGROUND CHECK INTO THE
ALLEGATIONS MADE BY PROFESSOR
CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD.
ONLY A WEEK, SENATOR JEFF FLAKE
SAT DOWN WITH ONE OF HIS
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES ON
"60 MINUTES" TO PAT HIMSELF ON
THE BACK FOR HIS HEROIC MOMENTS.
HE DID ADMIT IN THE INTERVIEW
THAT HE WAS SEEKING REELECTION,
HE WOULD NEVER WOULD HAVE DONE
THIS.
EVER.
HE CAME TO THE DEMOCRATIC
DEMANDS, HE IS NO OTHER HERO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU HAVE ANNOUNCE THAT YOU
ARE NOT RUNNING FOR REELECTION,
COULD HE HAVE DONE THIS?
>> NO.
[LAUGHS]
NOT A CHANCE.
>> NOT A CHANCE.
>> BECAUSE POLITICS HAVE BECOME
TOO SHARP, TOO PARTISAN?
>> THERE IS NO VALUE TO REACHING
ACROSS THE AISLE, THERE IS NO
COURTESY, THERE IS NO INCENTIVE.
>> Hannity: TONIGHT THE FBI'S
BACKGROUND CHECK INTO CHRISTINE
BLASEY FORD, THESE ARE ALL
IMPORTANT FACTS YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER.
IT IS WELL UNDERWAY.
RACHEL MITCHELL, TO REMEMBER
HER?
THE QUESTION BOTH PROFESSOR FORD
AND JUDGE KAVANAUGH, SHE HAS
ALREADY RELEASED HER REPORT TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND THESE
FINDINGS.
THEY ARE DEVASTATED.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID, A HE
SAID, SHE SAID CASE IS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO PROVE
BUT THIS CASE IS EVEN WEAKER
THAN THAT.
DR. FORD IDENTIFIED OTHER
WITNESSES TO THE EVENT AT THOSE
WITNESSES EITHER REFUTED HER
ALLEGATIONS WERE FAILED TO
COOPERATE THEM.
FOR THE REASONS DISCUSSED BELOW
I DO NOT THINK ANY REASONABLE
PROSECUTOR WOULD BRING THIS CASE
BASED ON THE EVIDENCE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
THE PROSECUTOR WENT ON TO LIST
MULTIPLE ISSUES WERE PROFESSOR
FORD'S ALLEGATIONS INCLUDING NO
CONSISTENT ACCOUNT AND WHEN THE
ALLEGED ASSAULT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED, A FAILURE TO PROGRESS
IDENTIFY JUDGE KAVANAUGH AS HE
IS SALIENT.
A FAILURE TO MEMBER KEY DETAILS
INCLUDING WHO REMEMBERED HIM TO
THE PARTY, HOW SHE GOT TO THE
PARTY AND WHERE THE PARTY EVEN
TOOK PLACE.
HOW SHE GOT HOME FROM THE PARTY.
SHE DOES HOWEVER REMEMBER
UNRELATED DETAILS LIKE THE
CONSUMPTION OF EXACTLY ONE BEER
AND THAT SHE TOOK NO MEDICATION
THAT DAY.
ANOTHER ISSUE LISTED BY
PROSECUTORS, IT SURROUNDS THE
FACT THAT HER ALLEGATIONS HAVE
BEEN COOPERATED BY NOBODY.
INCLUDING A LIFELONG FRIEND.
DR. FORD ALSO STRUGGLED TO
RECALL RECENT EVENTS RELATED TO
HER ALLEGATIONS INCLUDING THE
DATE OF A POLYGRAPH TEST.
ALSO INCONSISTENCIES WITH HER
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA CLAIMS
INCLUDING HER FEAR OF FLYING AND
THE FACT THAT SHE FLIES
FREQUENTLY IN MANY OF HER
HOBBIES INCLUDE FLYING ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
RACHEL MITCHELL REPORTING
ACTIVITIES OF DEMOCRATS AND HER
ATTORNEYS LIKELY AFFECTED HER
ACCOUNT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
SENATOR FEINSTEIN, THIS IS WHERE
WE GET INTO FACTS MATTER.
COOPERATION MATTERS, SHE
MENTIONED THESE FOUR PEOPLE.
NONE OF THEM COOPERATED HER
STORY INCLUDING AN ALLEGED
EYEWITNESS TO THE INCIDENT.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN PLAYED POLITICS
WITH PROFESSOR FORD'S VERY
SERIOUS CLAIMS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
SHE KNEW ABOUT THIS IN JULY.
LAST WEEK SENATE DEMOCRATS
DEMANDING AN FBI INVESTIGATION,
FEINSTEIN AND HER COLLEAGUES
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THIS AS I SAID
SINCE JULY.
THIS CALLS FOR INVESTIGATION
INTO KEITH ELLISON?
FOR THAT MATTER, ONE AT
BILL CLINTON?
WHY DIDN'T SENATOR FEINSTEIN ASK
BRETT KAVANAUGH WHEN THEY MET
PERSONALLY?
WHY AT THE VERY SAME TIME THAT
SHE IS ADVISING PROFESSOR FORD
ON WHAT ATTORNEY TO HIRE,
INSTEAD OF CONTACTING HER WITH A
QUALIFIED AND EXPERIENCED
NONPARTISAN LAWYER?
FEINSTEIN SUGGESTED A PARTISAN
LEFT WINGER.
BIG-TIME DEMOCRATIC DONOR.
ONCE BE CLAIMED ON NATIONAL TV,
SHE WOULD RESIST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SHE DISMISSED PAULA JONES.
IT WAS ONLY TEN, TO 12 MINUTES.
EXCUSE ME, HE EXPOSED HIMSELF.
BILL CLINTON AT THE TIME COMES
THAT WAS THE ALLEGATION.
SHE DEFENDED AL FRANKEN.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM THE
WASHINGTON BEACON, ONE OF HER
CLOSE FRIENDS IS NOW SEARCHING
FOR ANYONE WILLING TO COME
FORWARD AGAINST BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THEY ARE SENDING OUT EMAILS TO
PEOPLE.
LITERALLY SOLICITING PEOPLE AS
LATE AS LAST WEEK.
FEINSTEIN CARED ABOUT GETTING TO
THE TRUTH, WHY A DEMOCRATIC HACK
EVENTS CONSIST ON WHAT IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE?
MEANWHILE EVEN THOUGH PROFESSOR
FORD REQUESTED HER NAME REMAIN
PRIVATE, IT WAS LEAKED.
THE CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS ARE
THE ONLY OFFICIALS WITH ACCESS
TO HER STORY AND SENATE
REPUBLICANS ARE NOW BOWING
RIGHTLY SO TO INVESTIGATE DIANNE
FEINSTEIN THE DEMOCRATIC
HANDLING OF THIS CASE.
SHE IS DENYING ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE LEAK BUT
EARLIER TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
CALLED OUT THE SENATOR FOR HER
SHAMELESS POLITICAL PRACTICE AND
THEY WERE SHAMELESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DIANNE FEINSTEIN KNEW ABOUT
THIS TWO MONTHS EARLIER.
IF SHE WANTED A REALLY THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION, WE HAD ALL THE
TIME IN THE WORLD.
SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO WAIT TILL
AFTER THE HEARING WAS CLOSED.
ESSENTIALLY.
SHE SHOULD HAVE SAID LISTEN, I
HAVE A PROBLEM.
I HAVE THIS REPORT.
I WOULD LIKE THE FBI TO LOOK AT
IT WHILE WE ARE DOING THE
HEARING.
WE HAD TWO MONTHS.
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO BE TALKING
ABOUT, WE WANT MORE TIME FOR THE
FBI, IF YOU WANTED MORE TIME
WITH THE FBI, WHY DIDN'T DIANE
FEINSTEIN BRING THIS UP?
>> Hannity: WHY DIDN'T SHE?
AMERICA DESERVES AN ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION.
WHY DID SHE TELL HER REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUE, WE NEED TIME, WE
CAN'T RUSH THIS.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF TIME DEMOCRATS
HAVE CONTINUED THEIR POLITICAL
STALL TACTICS.
LAST WEEK IT WAS A NARROW
INVESTIGATION, LIMITED TO ONLY A
WEEK AND I DESPITE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ORDERING THE
FBI TO INVESTIGATE ANY AND ALL
LEGITIMATE CLAIMS, IT IS STILL
NOT ENOUGH FOR THE LEFT.
THEY WANT FBI INVESTIGATIONS AND
EVERY SINGLE CLAIM MADE AGAINST
BRETT KAVANAUGH NO MATTER HOW
UNSUBSTANTIATED AND SOME ARE
EVEN CALLING FOR AN
INVESTIGATION INTO WHETHER OR
NOT HE LIED ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU
DRINK IN HIGH SCHOOL.
HE SAID SOMETIMES HE DRANK A
LOT.
LIKE A LOT OF KIDS IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE.
THAT IS CALLED MOVING THE GOAL
POST, THAT IS CALLED MOVING THE
GAME.
THEY WANT TO STALL THE
NOMINATION, THEY WANT THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS, THESE FACTS
ALL MATTER.
36 DAYS, YOU, WE COME WITH THE
PEOPLE, DO YOU WANT TO PUT THESE
PEOPLE IN POWER?
THEY WERE TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, THEY WANT THEIR
CRIMES BACK AND THEY WANT TO
OPEN THE BORDERS AND THEY WANT
TO KEEP OBAMACARE.
IF THE FBI DOES EXTEND THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE SECOND
ACCUSER THAN THE THIRD ACCUSER
WE ARTY KNOW ABOUT THE SECOND
ACCUSER WE FIND AGAIN, ON SUCH
EDUCATED CLAIMS FROM A WOMAN WHO
CLAIMS THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH MAY
HAVE EXPOSED HIMSELF TO
HER IN A DRUNKEN COLLEGE PARTY
WHEN HE WAS A FRESHMAN.
SHE DOESN'T REALLY REMEMBER IN
FACTORIES THAT SHE WASN'T FULLY
SURE IF HE WAS THE PERPETRATOR.
SHE CALLED AROUND ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TO SEE IF
THEY REMEMBERED THE INCIDENT
WHETHER IT WAS HIM.
THEY DID NOT.
SHE EVEN ACKNOWLEDGES THAT SHE
HAS SIGNIFICANT MEMORY GAPS FROM
THAT EVENING.
"NEW YORK TIMES" REFUSES TO
WRITE THE STORY.
IN THIS CASE THE FBI IS LIKELY
TO FIND A LOT OF INCONSISTENCIES
FROM HER WHILE DELEGATIONS PAID
REMEMBER, SHE IS CLAIMING THAT
BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS INVOLVED IN
A SERIAL DRUGGING AND GANG RAPE
THAT HAPPENED ALMOST EVERY
WEEKEND IN THE 80s.
SHE WENT TO TEN OF THESE
PARTIES, TODAY SHE IS
REPRESENTED BY THE ALL FAME
SEEKING ATTORNEY MICHAEL NAVA
LOTTIE, THE NEW FACE PARTY SAT
DOWN WITH NBC NEWS.
BY THE END OF THE DAY IT WILL BE
A DISASTER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN THAT STATEMENT SHE SAID
SHE BECAME AWARE OF EFFORTS BY
BRETT KAVANAUGH AND HIS FRIEND
TO SPIKED PUNCH AT PARTIES.
IN HER INTERVIEW SHE SAID SHE
SAW THEM NEAR THE PUNCH BUT DID
NOT SPECIFICALLY SHE SAW EITHER
MAN TO SPIKE IT.
DID YOU SEE BRETT KAVANAUGH
SPIKING THE PUNCH?
>> I SAW HIM GIVING RED SOLO
CUPS TO QUITE A FEW GIRLS' NIGHT
TIME.
I SAW HIM AROUND THE PUNCH.
THE CONTAINER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE DID.
I SAW HIM BUY THEM.
>> ARE THEIR FRIENDS WHO MEMBER
THESE PARTIES TO?
>> I THINK EVERYONE IN
THE COUNTY OF THESE PARTIES.
>> WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THOSE
FRIENDS.
I AM ASKING, ARE THE PEOPLE
ALIVE TODAY?
>> YES, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
KNOW ABOUT THOSE PARTIES.
>> THIS MORNING SHE PROVIDED
FOUR NAMES OF FRIENDS WHO WENT
TO THOSE PARTIES WITH HER, ONE
OF THEM SAYS SHE DOES NOT RECALL
THAT.
ANOTHER FRIEND IS DECEASED.
WE HAVE REACH OUT TO THE OTHER
TWO AND HAVEN'T HEARD BACK.
>> Hannity: STILL COME AS YOUR
COOPERATION, THE SAME NBC NEWS
THAT SET ON THAT INTERVIEW WHEN
SHE WAS MAKING ALLEGATIONS ABOUT
BILL CLINTON.
THEY REFUSED TO AIR THAT FOR
OVER A MONTH ALL BECAUSE THEY
SAID IT COULDN'T BE COOPERATED.
THEY NEEDED TIME TO VENT IT.
NBC, THIS IS A DISGRACE.
THIS IS NOT NEWS.
THIS IS THEM LETTING AN
INDIVIDUAL MAKE ON COOPERATED
CLAIMS AND THEN JUST AIRING IT.
HERE THEY ARE RUNNING TOTALLY
UNVERIFIED CLAIMS AGAINST JUDGE
KAVANAUGH AND MULTIPLE
INCONSISTENCIES YET AGAIN.
ARE THERE ANY NEWS STANDARDS
OVER THERE?
SHOULD WE ALL BE SURPRISED?
THIS IS NOW A DISASTER FOR
NBC NEWS.
BY THE WAY, TOM BROKAW IF YOU'RE
WATCHING AND IF SOMEBODY CALLS
YOU IN 3 MINUTES, WILL YOU ERR
THIS?
YOU NEED TO SPEAK OUT PUBLICLY.
HE SPENT HER WHOLE LEG TRYING TO
BUILD THAT BRAND.
ALL THREE OF THESE STORIES, THEY
HAVE ONE THING IN COMMON, ZERO
COOPERATING EVIDENCE.
OUTRIGHT DENIALS OF SO-CALLED
WITNESSES AND MANY
INCONSISTENCIES.
AFTER ALL, THIS IS HOW YOUR
MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS NOW TREATING
THE ONGOING SUPREME COURT
BATTLE.
THIS WEEK AND A CARTOONIST DREW
THIS FILE DEPICTION OF JUDGE
KAVANAUGH'S YOUNG DAUGHTER,
PRAYING FOR HER ANGRY, LYING,
ALCOHOLIC FATHER FOR ASSAULTING
DR. FORD.
AND NEVER MADE INTO A NEWSPAPER.
THERE CARTOONIST PUBLISH IT
ONLINE ON HIS OWN.
HE DIDN'T RETURN OUR REQUEST FOR
COMMENTING, SHOCKING.
JAMES COMEY, HE OF COURSE IS
CALLING FOR AN UNLIMITED TIME
FRAME FOR FBI INVESTIGATIONS AND
BASHING ANYBODY, HE WON'T SIT
DOWN WITH INVESTIGATORS "MOST
PEOPLE WILL SPEAK TO THE FBI
REFUSAL TO DO SO IS ITS OWN KIND
OF STATEMENT."
I AM THINKING, REALLY?
ASK A GENERAL FLINT ABOUT
SPEAKING TO THE FBI.
THAT WORKED OUT PERFECT FOR
THEM.
IN THE CASE OF EVEN GENERAL
FLINT, THEY DIDN'T THINK HE
LIED.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH LYING.
WHEN YOU SEE ALL OF THESE BRETT
KAVANAUGH OFF BEDS COME ASKING
FOR MORE INFORMATION AND USE THE
MEDIA RUSHING TO JUDGMENT.
WHEN YOU SEE DEMOCRATS DEMANDING
MORE AND MORE INVESTIGATION, YOU
HAVE TO REMEMBER THIS ONE CLEAR
POINT AND THIS IS WHAT MATTERS
TONIGHT, THIS IS ALL ABOUT
POLITICS.
IT IS NOT ABOUT POWER.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THE TRUTH.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN AGAINST
BRETT KAVANAUGH PUBLICLY FROM
THEY DID THAT HE WAS ANNOUNCED.
NO MATTER WHAT THIS
INVESTIGATION FINDS, THEY WILL
NEVER VOTE FOR THEM ANYWAY.
THEY NEVER WERE.
IT IS LIKELY EVERY SINGLE REPORT
AND EVENT IN MODERN HISTORY.
THIS IS A MATTER THAT WE BETTER
GET RIGHT.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE EVIDENCE AND
YOU ARE GOING TO RUSH TO
JUDGMENT AND YOU WILL HAVE ZERO
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE, BY THE
WAY THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME.
FERGUSON, MISSOURI, RICHARD
JEWELL, THE BALTIMORE, MARYLAND,
THE CAMBRIDGE POLICE, DUKE
LACROSSE, NOW JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
CLARENCE THOMAS.
WE HAVE A PARTY OF SMEARS,
SLANDER, LIES AND NO DUE
PROCESS.
NON!
THEY SHOULD BE POLITICAL.
ALL THE LEFT-WING FRIENDS IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THE DEEP STATE
ARE BACKING THEM UP.
THERE IS NO LIGHT THEY'RE NOT
WILLING TO DESTROY FOR POWER.
NO REPUTATION.
THERE IS NO PROCESS.
NO ISSUE THEY WANT TO
POLITICIZE.